en pleine après-midi un incendie dans ce
camping du bas
ce vacancier s'enfuit à toute vitesse
tout autour les habitants filment les
pépannage de fumée assemblée générale de
Total perturbé en ce moment par des ONG
la réunion des actionnaires a débuté
dans une salle presqueville parce que
des militants de Greenpeace ou encore
les Amis de la Terre bloquent les
principaux accès le feu se propage très
rapidement à cause de l'explosion de
bouteilles de gaz dans les bungalows
sur la plage
[Musique]
le suspect Salvador Ramos en américain
de 18 ans aurait d'abord tiré sur sa
grand-mère avant de se rendre en voiture
dans l'école où il a été scolarisé pro
c'est trop
c'est trop c'est motivations sont
inconnues mais sur son compte Instagram
il a publié des photos de lui et d'armes
pour l'amour de Dieu allons-nous
affronter le lobby des armes
pour l'amour de Dieu allons nous faire
ce que nous savons tous pertinemment
qu'il faut faire réaction d'Emmanuel
Macron ce matin le choc et la peine du
peuple américain la colère de ceux qui
luttent pour mettre fin en violence nous
les partageons le pape François s'est
également exprimé il dit avoir le cœur
brisé il condamne le commerce incontrôlé
des armes ça n'arrive que dans ce pays
nulle part ailleurs
nulle part ailleurs les enfants vont à
l'école en pensant qu'ils pourront être
tués dans la journée Damien crie son
innocence il a sa part de vérité
également il faut qu'il soit écouté je
peux pas dire autre chose en tout cas
tout ces procès sur la place publique
sont terribles tous ces gens qui sont
des procureurs sont terribles et à la
présomption d'innocence mais on oublie
souvent de parler de la présomption de
sincérité qui est quelque chose de
reconnu par l'ONU d'ailleurs c'est à
dire le fait que la parole des femmes
qui
témoignent soit autant prise en compte
que la parole du présumé agresseur je
pense qu'on ne peut dans l'état que dire
à Monsieur Damien VAT qui ne peut pas
faire partie du gouvernement peut-être
le temps que la justice s'explique enfin
du moins que lui s'explique devant la
justice c'est que la justice prenne des
décisions que les femmes puissent leurs
paroles à nouveau être mieux prises en
compte je crois qu'il y a un témoignage
qui avait amené ce qui est une plainte
qui a été faite qui d'ailleurs a été
peut-être traitée de manière un peu
légère si cette présomption de sincérité
était plus appliquée je pense que la
parole des femmes se libérerait plus
facilement parce que c'est difficile de
témoigner j'en ai croisé c'est
comportements posent problème
c'est-à-dire que de dire une femme vient
demander un appartement oui bah une
petite faveur sexuelle l'autre il dit
ouais elle veut pas mais je voudrais
quand même qu'elle m'envoie ses seins
par vidéo ou par SMS enfin il y a un
moment donné il y a un problème de
comportement selon les informations de
BFM TV l'Élysée était bien au courant
d'une plainte classée sans suite en 2017
visant le nouveau ministre des
Solidarités accusé de viol par deux
femmes en 2017 et 2011 même lorsque nous
dit la presse aujourd'hui c'est que
notamment dans le groupe LR dans auquel
participait monsieur Abad c'était connu
qui avait cette histoire et donc il y a
une légèreté je pense vis-à-vis du
gouvernement vis-à-vis vous ne croyez
pas manger le parquet de Paris annonce
cet après-midi quand l'État je cite il
n'ouvre pas d'enquête il dit ne pas
disposer d'assez d'éléments permettant
d'identifier la victime d'effets
dénoncer
avait le journal people avait annoncé
que Sarah knyfo était enceinte d'Éric
Zemmour a-t-elle été enceinte d'Éric
Zemmour je prends soin de préciser que
notre livre est pas un livre people sous
la ceinture c'est un livre politique
mais nous l'a confié elle a jamais été
enceinte nouveau record du monde battu
par un Français celui de la plus grande
distance parcourue sur un fil tendu le
funambule n’attan Polin a marché un peu
plus de 2 km sur un fil au
Mont-Saint-Michel